in this video i'm going to be breaking
down episode 11 of attack on titan
season 4
in which aaron's army of supporters
begin to cause trouble on parodies
island
and mali strategize how they're going to
get revenge this video will break down
what's going on with that plus
everything else that i thought was
interesting
including gabby and falco's adventure
and whether the rumbling is going to
happen or not
the politics surrounding the rumbling
can get a bit confusing so i tried to
break it down as straightforwardly as
possible in this video
before we begin be sure to hit that sub
button as we are on the road to 250k
which would be a massive milestone and
i'd also appreciate if you dropped a
like as it does help out the video
okay so episode 11 was called deceiver
and the title is likely a reference to
zeke deceiving mali
or elena possibly deceiving the military
by having a secret meeting with erin
that being said the first true deception
of the episode came in the opening scene
when gabby pretended to have some kind
of seizure only to brutally assault the
guard who came to check up on her
what gabby did here was remove a brick
from a nearby wall and then wrap it up
in the same jacket that she was wearing
when she arrived
gabby's brutality when attacking this
guy was completely unhinged
like you didn't need to hit him five
times i'm sure even just twice would
have knocked him out completely but it
was her belief that they were going to
be killed
with the exception of flock i highly
doubt anyone would have been on board
with killing them
but as we already know gabi is a very
paranoid individual
back in mali rhino wakes up after
hearing gabby and falco's voices in a
dream
and in all likelihood he was probably
having a nightmare about the raid in
mali
because that's when both kids were
crying out to him galliard offers reiner
a drink as he wonders where the warrior
candidates are
and there's a couple things i want to
point out here number one is that with
zeke now defecting to parodies
reiner is by default the new captain of
the warriors as he was previously vice
captain before aaron did his thing
i just found this really interesting
because it was established early this
season that reiner was the weakest
candidate who was never even meant to be
a warrior in the first place
so it's kind of funny that he's managed
to stumble his way to the top
the second thing was that porker had
been drowning his sorrows in a bottle of
wine
showing for the third time that marley
and wine might just be the best in the
attack on titan universe
the anime then goes back to gabby and
falco who had been running so long that
it was now the morning
as they take a breather gabby insists on
still wearing her warrior canada armband
despite the fact that it could easily
identify them as eldians from mali
she's been conditioned to believe that
aliens on the island are intrinsically
more evil than the good aliens who live
in mali
we saw during the dinner at the brown
household that you know these guys just
talk about this all the time even when
they're having dinner
rana's mother still made it a point to
teach gabby about how evil the aliens on
the island are
the armband symbolizes to her that she
is different from those aliens on the
island
and therefore if she wants to take it
off then it would almost be admitting
that they are the same
that's what made this moment from falco
so savage as he just straight up rips
the thing off gabby's arm
the two then have a brief altercation
but interrupted by kaya
who was the girl that had a life saved
by sasha four years ago
ever since that day she was taken in by
sasha's parents and now lives on their
family farm alongside other orphans who
had nowhere else to go
during a morning walk she happens to
overhear these two arguing and politely
ask where they're from
obviously the warrior candidates
couldn't tell the truth but can we
appreciate that in this moment
gabby was prepared to bash another
person's head in anyway kaya invites
these two back to her family home
and there is just a lot to unpack from
this moment onwards the first issue is
that this man is sasha's father
this woman is sasha's mother and this
crazy person is the one that kills sasha
but neither of them know that gabby has
no idea that this is the family of the
person she murdered
and these guys have no reason to suspect
that gabby was the killer
as a result we get this bizarre
situation in which sasha's parents
accept the warrior candidates into their
home
offering for them to stay as long as
they need this brings us to the next
point
which is that in order to conceal their
identities falco claimed that he and
gabby were siblings
and that their names are ben and mia
that's right people
falco just brother zoned himself without
even realizing it
throughout this whole scene we saw what
are possibly the first steps towards
gabby realizing that all aliens are the
same
regardless of where they're born upon
entering the house gabby realizes that
sasha's father
has an accent that she's heard before in
mali that accent is sort of like a
countryside twang that is
typical for people in this region and
sasha actually had that same accent but
she tried to hide it during her time in
the scouts
the reason this is important is because
gabby clearly knows people back home
with this same accent
so the fact it's coming from someone
who's supposed to be a devil
it's something that humanizes the aliens
on parodies and makes them seem
less like monsters and more like the
regular aliens that gabby herself knows
the next step that gabby took towards
enlightenment was when she decided to
eat the food that was made by sasha's
mother
after previously saying that she would
never eat with devils hermalian
programming was already in full effect
as we saw when she slapped away sash's
mother's hand
so clearly it would have taken a lot for
her to actually you know eat food made
by an
aldian from parodies and not only do
that but eat it alongside them as well
at this same time ambassador kiyomi had
touched down on parodies island
and although she appeared in the
flashback last week this is her first
appearance in the present day
since the declaration of war given what
eren just did
it is a big risk for her to come to the
island physically however she does have
a good reason for doing so
for the past three years the nation of
his roo has had an alliance with
parodies and have been using the iceberg
stone to develop new technology
one of their new creations is this
flying boat that requires the iceberg
stone to work
and kyomi intends to use it so she can
observe the partial rumbling of the
earth
considering that aaron and zeke have
been separated you might be confused as
to whether parodies is or isn't planning
to do a rumbling
so i'm going to break down the whole
situation based off current information
to begin a rumbling was always on the
cards for parodies from day one
but the flashbacks made it clear that
they wanted to explore other
alternatives before they had to use it
over the years parodies tried different
ways of making peace with other nations
but none of those worked otherwise we
wouldn't be where we are by aaron
attacking marley in the present day
a partial rumbling of the earth is now
necessary because the rest of the world
is going to attack them pretty soon
the problem for the military is that
although they know a rumbling is
necessary
they don't trust eren or zeke to do it
because if these two make contact then a
lot of things can happen
if aaron and zeke make contact then in
theory aaron has control over every
alien in the world
he could manipulate their memories he
could turn them into titans he could
change their physiology he can literally
do whatever he wants
so they don't trust him to be the one to
do it that's why aaron and zeke are
currently separated
but the military is still preparing for
the rumbling to happen
we know this because in this episode
kiyomi has arrived to observe the
rumbling in our flying boats
and more importantly thanks to reeves we
know that a forced evacuation of
shiganshina is currently underway
shiganchena is one of the outermost
parts of the wall so if a partial
rumbling was to happen
then it makes sense to start there
residents are likely being evacuated
because if a partial rumbling is to
start then it's possible that homes
could be destroyed
by falling debris or even the wall
titans themselves
therefore with all this evidence that
the military is getting ready to rumble
how are they going to make that happen
if they don't trust aaron the truth is
that we don't know for sure at this
stage
but armin mentioned in the last episode
that one option is to feed aaron to
someone they can trust
and in theory that person could then
activate the rumbling instead
that's pretty much all there is to it at
this moment so i hope that cleared up
most of the rumbling situation
but without further ado let's move on to
hanji being confronted by this mob
at military headquarters most of this
mob are here for one reason only and
that is to ensure the freedom of eren
yeager
and it's important to note that the
military have not told the population
that aaron was arrested to fight back
against this lack of information
flock and a few of the new recruits have
been spreading rumors among the
population
to rally up support for eren's freedom
the people in the crowd can't understand
why their hero
is being imprisoned by the military and
hanji wasn't exactly giving any answers
that would put them at ease
this plan from flock was really smart
because if support for aaron continues
to spread
then it will become more and more
difficult for the military to justify
keeping him in jail
it would also be more difficult for them
to justify someone eating eren
because if the population perceives
aaron as a hero then how are you gonna
feed him to some random soldier like it
just doesn't make sense
flock tells hendry to her face that not
only should eren be freed but he should
also lead the new alien empire
although someone should remind him that
aaron does only have four years left to
live
so you know even if he is the new leader
he won't be able to lead for very long
[ __ ] takes a tough stance and has them
all sent to prison for leaking
information
but i gotta say it's fascinating that
aaron has such a level of support
that people are happily willing to do
jail time to support him
whilst flocking the recruits are led
away hanji remembers the warning that
sanes gave her last season
at that time hanji was in a similar
position to what flock is right now
in that she was fighting against the
establishment to forcibly make political
change
silence was tortured by both hanji and
levi and was eventually tricked into
sharing information
that led to historia taking the throne
the reason she remembers what sane has
said here
is because he warned her that no matter
who's in charge someone is always
destined to play the role of the
establishment and the role of the rebel
back then hanji was the rebel but now in
the present day
she's one of the main people in charge
and has to deal with rebels like flock
also by hanji refusing to tell the
people information about eren's
imprisonment
she's basically doing exactly what
characters like saunas used to do
which is that they say they're
protecting the people by keeping them in
the dark about important issues that
affect them
anyway down in the prison cells we got
an awesome throwback to a character
we've literally not seen for years
and that is louise in season 1 after war
rose was breached
titans began pouring in to trust with
many citizens trying to escape
luis and her mother were among the
evacuees but their escape path was
blocked by dima reeves who at the time
was the head of the reeves company
a fast abnormal titan then began
approaching them and if it wasn't for
mikasa everyone likely would have died
but she managed to breeze past the other
scouts and just killed this thing
with almost no effort she then
threatened to kill reeves for
endangering the citizens
and you know this naturally convinced
him to move the wagon
this was definitely an iconic mikasa
moment and in the eyes of a young louise
i think it's fair to say that mikasa
became her hero all these years later
luis is now a new recruit in the survey
corps and part of the reason she joined
was to get slightly closer to mikasa
like flock she's of the belief that
aaron should be freed
because the power of the rumbling
ensures elder's survival
as mikasa leaves louise gives her a nice
salute which was her paying respects to
when mikisa gave her that salute when
she was a child
for some currently unknown reason mika's
head painfully begins to throb
as her mind flashes back to when eren
saved her from those kidnappers
this memory was triggered by what luis
had said during their conversation
but it's not the first time that this
has happened to mikasa way back in
episode 2 of attack on titan
the titans were causing chaos in
jaganchina and mikasa's head began to
throb
as she remembered what happened to her
parents for mikasa
something about traumatic events causes
this reaction in her brain
though currently we have no idea why the
anime then switches over to elena
who is under house arrest like the rest
of the malian volunteers
for those that missed my last review the
volunteers are currently being
restrained
because the military doesn't believe
that zeke is on their side and they
think that he's secretly plotting
something
because the volunteers are loyal to zeke
it was necessary to separate them once
he arrived on the island
so that they can't communicate with each
other or with him pixis begins to grill
elena
as the entire time she's been on the
island she's tried to make herself
appear squeaky clean
pixis notes that many months ago before
erin infiltrated mali
elena had flock assigned to her as a
guard and now he's in jail for trying to
build up support for eren among the
population
remember how when elena first appeared
she commented how excited she was to
finally see erin
and then in one of the other flashbacks
she tried to properly meet him but levi
got in the way
whatever elena is thinking she's clearly
a big fan of eren and obviously a big
fan of zeke as well
so there's something going on and it's
just very unclear what
pixie states that the place elena was
staying was not that far away from
aaron's home
meaning it's possible that with the help
of flock aaron and elena had a secret
meeting
if flock thought it was beneficial for
aaron to meet elena then yeah of course
he would let that happen so i guess
we'll find out the truth next week
now back in the stables gabby and falca
were working as farmhands
and even this horse can tell that gabby
has bad vibes most of the scene was
pretty self-explanatory but we did get
this moment when gabby asked falco why
he's not more angry with zeke
and the true reason is that he's not
really reacting to zeke's betrayal
because falco himself feels incredibly
guilty for the part that he played
everything that transpired would not
have happened if falco didn't deliver
those letters for aaron
so he doesn't feel quite right in being
totally angry with zeke
when he himself is at fault after this
moment when they're taking a break
kaya makes it clear that she knew they
were from mali the entire time
but chose not to say anything because
unlike a certain someone
kaia doesn't judge a person based on
where they're from for the remainder of
the episode gabby's mali and
brainwashing was working at nearly a
hundred percent
as she kept trying to justify everything
bad that's happened to both kaya
and the other orphans who live on the
farm her logic was that because of the
atrocities committed by the eldians
present-day aliens deserve anything bad
that happens to them of course that
logic doesn't quite check out
but the thing that really amazed me was
that gabby was so
insensitive that she would even say
these things on the spot
where kai's mother was literally eaten
by a titan why does falco like this girl
again like
what redeeming quality does gaby have
that makes him so in love with her
when he's clearly the only sane one
among the two of them in fact a few
episodes ago
falco tried to tell gabi that the attack
on mali was because mali attacked
parodies first
and gabby replied saying something like
did you see it so
i guess this is her literally seeing it
like this is what marley did so in that
sense it's quite poetic that she's here
the post-credits scene for this episode
occurs in mali and just before you start
freaking out not every episode has a
post-credit scene so don't go back
looking at the previous episodes
only like i think this is only the
second one to have one maybe the third
but anyway anyway the malian warriors
finally realized that zeke has betrayed
them
and there were a few things that gave
him away for example there is mali and
technology integrated into the scouts
equipment
and because peak knows that elena was
sent to paris a few years ago
it's kind of obvious that zeke was the
one who organized everything magath also
elaborates that zeke's full remains were
not found
from the perspective of the malians they
thought that there would be more stuff
in the beast titan but really it was
just his limbs
all the warriors take the news
differently with poco being the most
emotional as usual
but colt who is meant to be the next
beast titan is also quite concerned but
you know not as much as you might expect
that's because colt's main priority is
getting falco back home
which can only be done once mali decide
to launch their counter attack on
parodies
magat's idea is to wait six months
before they attack the island which gets
a big reaction out of colt because you
know that's way too long
but magath's reasoning is pretty sound
mcgath wants to give other countries
around the world enough time to prepare
and by doing this they can all attack
the island simultaneously
if that was to happen parodies would not
stand a chance the only way they would
survive
is if they had already activated the
rumbling otherwise there's just nothing
that would save them
from the entire world attacking them at
once that said
reiner argues that instead of waiting
they should launch a surprise attack on
the island straight away
as by doing that zeke and the rest of
the people on the island would be in no
way prepared
no one on paradise is expecting mali to
attack so soon
especially after armin destroyed a chunk
of their army so by launching a quick
attack
they can stop whatever zeke is planning
to do with that said that was my
breakdown for episode 11 of attack on
titan season 4.
as usual i'd appreciate if you dropped a
like if you liked this one and let me
know in the comments what you thought of
the episode
until the next one peace out